[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to another
episode of The Joy of mathematics if
you're an old viewer then you might know
that I like including my cats in these
videos and if you're new then let me
introduce you to Henry skittles and
ketchup in this video I have a special
announcement which is that I have just
released some chips for my channel and
this is the first design it is a Klein
bottle Kitty this is one that kit shop
modeled for and if you want to get one
I'll leave a link in the description and
it's a way that you can support my
channel and I really appreciate it
kit shop appreciates it to having his
face out there there are multiple colors
including black grey and red to
celebrate the shirts this video is going
to be dedicated to math for cats so
invite your cat over to watch this video
with you and you might learn a thing or
two we're going to learn how to select
the perfect cat for you how cats can
pick the best spot in which to sleep and
also look at some of the divine geometry
of a sleeping cat ketchup himself was
recently adopted by my family from a
rescue shelter but how did we know that
he was going to be the best cat for us
there were a lot of options to choose
from and we had looked for a little
while can be hard to know that you're
making the best choice but if we put our
thinking cats on we might actually be
able to use a little bit of math to
ensure the best chance of finding the
best cat if we say that every cat we
look at will be taken by someone else if
we don't take it then that means we
can't go back to a previous option and
we should only turn a cat down if we
think the best is still to come
but that could lead to disappointment
because we don't know what's out there
and we don't know if the best has
already passed us by we need to strike a
balance between looking at options to
gather data and taking whatever meets
the standards that we've established I'm
going to treat this as an optimum
stopping problem which is a common class
of problems in maths and computer
science which balance
looking and leaping max allows us to
work out this balance exactly and it
works out to be a 37 percent if you want
to maximize your odds at finding the
best option you should look at 37
percent of the options just looking not
committing to anything just calibrating
and gathering data and then after 37
percent of the options you should take
the next one which is better than all
the ones you've seen so far so let's
have a little look at this if we had
just one option to choose from then of
course we should just take it if we had
two options then the best we can do is a
50% chance of finding the best cat
either we take the first one and leave
the second or we take the second and
leave the first we can't really do any
better than chance but for three cats we
can do better than chance if we were to
just pick one randomly we would have a
one over three or 33% chance of finding
the best cat but we can do better than
that
with the first cat we have no
information and with the last cat we
have no option we just have to take it
by the time we get there but with the
middle cat we have a bit of both so if
we decide that the first cat we look at
we're never going to get it we're just
going to use it as a way to gather data
about the next two then we'll look at
the first cat and only accept the second
cat if it is better than the first one
if it's not then we'll leave it and move
on and take the third cat that actually
increases our chance of finding the best
cat out of the 3 to 50% which is better
than chance as you start to look at more
and more options the percentage of the
options that you should look through
converges to be 37% which is 1 over E
the mathematical number Oilers number by
some nice symmetry this method also
gives us a 37% chance of finding the
best option we can apply this to time
too so if you want
set aside six months to find the perfect
cat or 180 days then you should relax
and just look for the first 66 days
about two months and then after that
time period except the next cat you see
which is better than all the ones you've
seen so far in reality people often stop
their search actually before it is
optimal to do so and that's because
there are a few factors that I haven't
considered here and one of them is the
cost to keep looking in reality there is
a cost of your time to keep going and
looking at all these cats to gather data
and calibrate and there's also a bit of
an emotional cost to keep saying no to
the cats you look at so I would forgive
you for stopping your search a little
early
[Music]
[Music]
now we are going to tackle the topic of
exploring versus exploiting and which
balance of those two things can lead to
the most fulfilling life or the most
fulfilling outcome in terms of our cats
and their problems that we're trying to
solve one thing I've noticed is that
ketchup my little kitten is constantly
exploring and looking for new places to
sleep he hasn't quite figured out where
the best places are yet and he hasn't
really found a favorite spot Skittles
seems to do a lot less exploring of new
places and more exploiting at a place
that she's already decided is pretty
good the Explorer versus exploit problem
comes up many places in our own lives
and one example to illustrate one kind
of solution would be to imagine that
you're in a casino and there's a whole
bunch of slot machines all with a
different probability of being giving
you a win of being successful now if you
had a hundred pulls so you could use a
hundred turns on any of the levers what
would you do so you'd have to balance
some sort of exploring at the start you
figure out which of the slot machines
has good probability of giving your win
and then trying to exploit those ones
that you find a good it wouldn't make as
much sense to just randomly take turns
on different machines throughout your
100 pulls because you haven't exploited
any of the good machines but you also
wouldn't want to spend your whole time
exploiting just one machine because it
might not have been the best one to use
all your turns on the mathematical
solution here does depend a lot on how
long you have to spend in the casino or
how long you have to enjoy the returns
of whatever it is that you're trying to
exploit you wouldn't want to find a
really good news sleeping spot on your
last day living at a certain house and
you wouldn't want to find a really good
new restaurant the day before you're
about to leave town you want to have
some time to be able to exploit what you
find one strategy is to stay with an
option as long as it keeps paying off as
long as it keeps giving you wins
but to switch to a different option just
because of one bad experience does seem
a little bit brash and it might have
just been one bad day you don't know
that it's necessarily a bad option a
better strategy could be to use
something in maths which is called the
Gittins
index but for the purpose of this video
we're going to refer to it as the
kittens index now this is a way to
mathematically maximize payoffs and it
takes into account that exploring an
unknown option can be better than just
sticking with a known one in this model
a good outcome today is worth more than
a good outcome tomorrow for example if
you believe that there's a 1% chance
that you might get hit by a car on any
given day then you should value
tomorrow's sleeping spot at 99 percent
of the value of today's sleeping spot
because you might never get to have it
so what we should do when considering
options is to always take the option
with the highest kittens number or
kittens number now these numbers
themselves are quite difficult to
calculate but what we can do is look up
values in a table that someone else has
already calculated and apply this table
to our own situation so I have a bit of
a table here and it has the number of
ones this is the number of losses so
this is the number of good experiences
we've had in a certain sleeping spot and
this is the number of bad experiences
we've had the values in this table are
as they say discounted by 99% so that
just means what I said before that a
good spot tomorrow is worth 99 percent
of the value of a good spot today there
are a few interesting things to note in
this table for example here an option of
0 0 so that's an option you have
absolutely no experience with them no
data about has a value of 0.87 and
that's actually higher than a lot of
other values around here it's higher
than this option here which has a win
two out of three times
and it has a value of 0.8 3 so it really
does value the idea of an unknown
experience because it might actually
really pay off but as you gain more and
more data so you go down this diagonal
here these are all options that are
actually 50/50 they have an expected
value of 50/50 it's either one lost one
when two losses two ends down to four
losses four ones if you keep going down
this diagonal you will eventually get to
0.5 which is the real probability there
or the real expected value but it
doesn't converge to 0.5 until you have
enough data to really be quite certain
that that's really what it is giving you
in terms of returns we can see through
these numbers that trying new things
increases our chance of finding the best
provided that we do have enough chance
to take advantage of it so if we take it
back to my example with my cats
maybe skittles has found a place to
settle down and exploit because maybe
she's found one with the value of 0.9
five ones with four wins and 0 losses
and that's higher than the completely
unknown option that you have no
experience about so it makes sense for
her to pick this option given that she
knows about it
however ketchup doesn't know about these
options yet and to him all of the new
options are worth quite a high value so
he might as well try them all out of
course he wouldn't go back to any of
these options down here which have very
low values much lower than the idea of
trying somewhere new and that makes
sense because these places here have
given a lot of bad experiences one of
the big assumptions that we're making
here is that the probabilities are fixed
over time so the probability of a spot
being good is not going to change in the
real world
maybe these probabilities are changing a
bit and so in that case it would make a
bit more sense to continuously explore
the probabilities because they could be
going up and down
[Music]
a last example of cat math that we're
going to talk about today relates to the
geometry of a sleeping cat and it also
relates to the Fibonacci or the fur
Bonacci numbers now these are the
numbers which I've got up here starting
with 1 1 2 and you add every number to
the number that came before it to get
the next one so 1 plus 1 is 2 2 plus 1
is 3 3 plus 2 is 5 5 plus 3 is 8 and you
keep on going like that now if you were
to take two of these numbers and find
the ratio between them so take 8 and
divide it by 5 you're going to get a
certain value and as you go further and
further along the sequence of numbers
that ratio between each number and get
closer to something called the golden
ratio and it's about one point six two
now this golden ratio doesn't just crop
up as the ratio between Fibonacci
numbers but it also is a ratio that
comes up a lot in geometry and some say
that to have the golden ratio in a shape
makes that shape very aesthetically
pleasing I'll draw a golden rectangle as
an example of one of these shapes for
you so in this rectangle and I'm not
using a ruler so please forgive me
the ratio between the lengths of the
sides between this side and the side is
about 1.6 or is the golden ratio
now we could keep splitting this
rectangle up so we could break this off
into a square here and then we'd have
another golden rectangle here do the
same thing down here and just keep going
like that getting more and more golden
rectangles now this set of golden
rectangles can make a spiral that crops
up anywhere from like a seashell just
different bits of geometry or you could
even go on a bit of a stretch and
that you could find a sleeping cat
within this shape a long tail there
it looks a little bit like a cat I've
definitely seen my cat sleeping in a
position like there's a few times and I
don't know if they do that to look as
aesthetically pleasing as possible or if
it's just a coincidence but thank you
for watching this episode of the joy of
mathematics I hope that you or your cat
maybe learned a thing or two and I hope
that you have an absolutely mathematical
day
[Music]